Once Upon A Time In This Nation there
was a a real purpose for unions safety
in the workplace things like that there
it was real there were kids working at
12 years old and factories for 10hour
days it was real and the combination of
Osha and unions brought some sensibility
and balance to the worker relationship
now you really don't need unions because
you have armies of trial attorneys that
can attack companies for work for
individual you know malfeasances or
things that happen to workers but now
the trickle down effect watch's the
trickle down effect Amazon drivers
unionize Amazon drivers want that Amazon
Prime is no longer available because
they can't afford to give it to you for
what is it 176 bucks a year or whatever
it is now and guess what now the cost of
everything goes
up there it comes Pat it's inflationary
you know the you want people to earn
more money to earn a living yes